It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正飞速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会错失的好优惠。立即探索 GoogleFi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Think about the last thing you shared online or via email with someone else. A funny video on TikTok, a news story you thought your friends would enjoy, or a new phrase you've been hearing everywhere. Chances are you didn't share it randomly. Something about it grabbed you and made you think, I have to pass this along. Every day we're bombarded with information, stories, ideas, and words.
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。想想你最近在网上或通过电子邮件与他人分享的第一样东西。TikTok 上的一个搞笑视频，一则你觉得朋友们会喜欢的新闻，或者你最近到处都能听到的一句新流行语。大概率你不是随机分享的。其中有什么东西触动了你，让你觉得：“我必须把这个转发出去。”每天我们都被铺天信息、故事、观点和词汇狂轰滥炸。
But we only feel compelled to share a fraction of that. Why? Why do some things catch on traveling through networks of conversations, texts and social media, while others disappear? And what can psychology tell us about why we share what we do? Do we share things differently online and in person? How are the changing social media landscape and artificial intelligence affecting how ideas spread? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
但我们只觉得其中一小部分值得分享。为什么？为什么有些事物能在对话、短信和社交网络的浪潮中流传开来，而另一些却消失得无影无踪？心理学能告诉我们关于“我们分享的原因”的什么信息？我们在网上和线下的分享方式有什么不同？不断变化的社交媒体格局和人工智能又是如何影响创意传播的？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
My guest today is Dr. Jonah Berger, a professor at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania and a leading researcher on word of mouth, social influence, and how ideas spread. He's the author of four books including magic words, what to say to get your way, and contagious why things catch on. He's published more than 80 articles in academic journals, and his research has been covered widely in mainstream media. His work looks at the psychological principles that help explain why certain products, messages, and ideas become popular, and how those same principles show up in our everyday conversations. Dr. Berger, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much for having me.
我今天的嘉宾是乔纳·伯格（Jonah Berger）博士，他是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的教授，也是口碑传播、社会影响力和创意传播领域的顶尖研究员。他是四本书的作者，包括《魔力词：如何用言语达成所愿》（Magic Words: What to Say to Get Your Way）以及《疯传：让你的产品、思想、行为自己会说话》（Contagious: Why Things Catch On）。他在学术期刊上发表了 80 多篇文章，其研究在主流媒体上得到了广泛报道。他的工作探讨了解释为什么某些产品、信息和想法会变得流行的心理学原理，以及这些原理是如何展现在我们的日常对话中的。伯格博士，非常感谢您今天能做客节目。非常感谢邀请我。
So I talked a moment ago about viral trends. A lot of people think that going viral is just due to chance or luck, but you've discovered there are patterns to what takes off. So more broadly, how does psychology drive what we share? You know, it's so interesting because we've all seen examples of things that catch on, right? Whether they be products at the grocery store, videos on social media, apps that everyone's telling us to download. But we often think it's random luck or chance why they became popular, that you just have to catch lightning in a bottle or something along those lines. But it turns out there's actually really a science behind it. We've analyzed thousands of pieces of online content, tens of thousands of brands, and millions of purchases,
刚才我谈到了病毒式传播的趋势。很多人认为病毒式传播纯粹是靠偶然或运气，但你发现流行趋势其实是有规律的。那么更广泛地说，心理学是如何驱动我们的分享行为的呢？你知道，这很有趣，因为我们都见过各种风靡一时的例子，对吧？无论是杂货店里的商品，社交媒体上的视频，还是每个人都让我们下载的应用。但我们常常认为它们之所以流行纯属随机的运气或机遇，觉得你只需要碰运气或诸如此类的情况。但事实证明，这背后其实有一套科学规律。我们分析了数千条在线内容、数万个品牌以及数百万笔购买，
both around the United States and around the world. And again and again, we see the same science coming up, the same six factors driving things to catch on and be shared. And so at the core, it's really about the psychology of social transmission. Why do we talk about certain things rather than others? Why do we share what we're doing this weekend or not talk about something that happened last weekend? And what about that science can help us understand why things become popular? And you've explained this in something you've called the Steps Framework, these six psychological reasons that people share things.
无论是在美国还是全球各地。一次又一次，我们发现相同的科学规律在起作用——推动事物流行并被分享的六大因素。所以其核心其实是社会传播的心理学。为什么我们谈论某些事情而不是其他事情？为什么我们分享这周末要做什么，而不是谈论上周末发生了什么？这种科学能如何帮助我们理解事物为什么会流行？你在所谓的“步骤框架”（Steps Framework）中解释了这一点，这是人们分享事物的六个心理原因。
Can you talk about what those steps are? Sure. So Steps is an acronym, and there's kind of six key dimensions there. The first S stands for social currency. The T stands for triggers. The E stands for motion. The first P is public. The second P is practical value.
你能谈谈这几个步骤是什么吗？当然可以。Steps 是一个缩写，其中有六个关键维度。第一个 S 代表社交货币（Social currency）。T 代表诱因（Triggers）。E 代表情绪（Emotion）。第一个 P 是公开性（Public）。第二个 P 是实用价值（Practical value）。
And the last S is stories. And each of those is a psychological driver of why people talk and why they share. It's not about certain products versus ideas versus services. It's not about business to consumer versus business to business. It's not about expensive things versus cheap things. It's really about the science of why things get passed on, right? Why do we talk about some things that happened to us last weekend and not others? Why do we talk about certain trips or vacations we took years ago, but not other ones?
最后一个 S 是故事（Stories）。每一个都是人们交谈和分享的心理驱动力。这无关特定的产品与想法或服务的对比，无关 B2C 与 B2B 的对比，也无关昂贵物品与廉价物品的对比。这真正关乎事物被代代相传的科学原理，对吧？为什么我们谈论上周末发生在我们身上的某些事而不是其他事？为什么我们谈论几年前的某些旅行或假期，而对另所有这些如何帮助我们理解事物为什么会流行？
And how does all this help us understand why things catch on? And the first reason you cite is social currency, the idea that people share things that make them look good or smart or knowledgeable. Why is social currency such a powerful driver of what we share? Sure. Is that right if I tell a story for a minute? Absolutely. Yeah. So there's this place in New York City, and I'm sure some of your listeners are from New York City, but many other folks have been there before. And so imagine you're walking around
你提到的第一个原因就是社交货币，即人们倾向于分享能让自己看起来优秀、聪明或博学的东西。为什么社交货币是我们分享行为如此强大的驱动力？当然。如果我讲一会儿故事，可以吗？完全可以。好的。纽约市有一个地方，我确信你们的听众中有些人来自纽约市，但也有很多其他人去过那里。所以想象一下，你正在
on like the Lower East Side of New York City. Your stomach is rumbling. You've got to get a bite to eat. When you notice a big hot dog-shaped sign out in front of a restaurant with the words eat me written on it would look like mustard, say, I haven't had a hot dog in a while. I'll check this place out. So you walk down a flight of stairs into a restaurant called Criff Dogs. And this place has an amazing range of hot dogs, right? It has a good morning hot dog with bacon, eggs, and cheese, a hot dog through an onion and pineapple, traditional Newark-style water dog, sort of every hot dog that you can imagine. But if you finish eating your hot dog, you might notice in the corner of the room is a phone booth. One of those old things that Clark Kent might
纽约市的下东区闲逛。你的肚子在咕咕叫。你得吃点东西填饱肚子。这时你注意到餐厅门外挂着一个巨大的热狗形招牌，上面用看起来像芥末酱的字写着“吃了我”（eat me），你想着：“我已经好久没吃热狗了。我去看看这家店。”于是你走下一段楼梯，进入一家名为 Criff Dogs 的餐厅。这家店提供种类惊人的热狗，对吧？它有加了培根、鸡蛋和奶酪的“早安热狗”，有加了洋葱和菠萝的热狗，有传统的纽瓦克式水煮热狗，几乎涵盖了你能想象到的所有热狗。但如果你吃完热狗，可能会注意到房间的角落里有一个电话亭。那种克拉克·肯特可能会
jump into to change into Superman. And so walk into the phone booth, slide open that door and walk inside. And on the wall, you'll see something you probably haven't seen in like 30 or 40 years, potentially even. It's a rotary-ed-out phone. One of those phones, you have to stick your finger into go around in a circle. So just for fun, stick your finger and say the number three, go around in a circle and hold the receiver up to your ear. Well, the phone will actually ring. It'll go ring, ring, and then someone will pick up the other line, and they'll ask you whether you have a reservation. And I remember the first time I heard this story. I said, I'm sitting in a phone booth inside of a hot dog restaurant. What will possibly have a reservation
跳进去变身超人的老式电话亭。于是你走进电话亭，拉开门走进去。在墙上，你会看到一个你可能已经有 30 或 40 年没见过、甚至可能从未见过的东西。那是一台老式的转盘电话。那种需要把手指伸进去转一圈的电话。所以，就当好玩，把手指伸进数字 3，转一圈，然后把听筒拿起来贴在耳边。电话真的会响。它会发出“叮铃铃”的声音，然后另一端会有人接听，并问你是否有预订。我记得我第一次听到这个故事时的情景。我说：“我正坐在一家热狗店里面的电话亭里。我究竟能预订什么？”但如果你运气好，他们恰好有空位，或者你的某个朋友恰好做了预订，那个电话亭的背面就会打开，你会被引领进入一家名为“请不要告诉别人”（Please Don’t Tell）的秘密酒吧。现在，“请不要告诉别人”违反了传统营销和传播的所有法则。街上没有招牌，餐厅里面也没有招牌。他们竭尽所能让自己难以被找到。然而，他们每天都客满。下午 3 点电话线路开通。到 3 点半，所有座位通常都被订光了。你必须一遍又一遍地重拨才能打通。我实际上去参观过“请不要告诉别人”。我花了好几个星期才进去，我是大约在周二晚上 6 点左右进去的——这并不是最受欢迎的时间。你可能会
for? But if you're lucky, and they happen to have space or a friend of yours happen to make a reservation, the back of that phone booth will open, and you'll be led into a secret bar called Please Don't Tell. Now, Please Don't Tell has violated all the traditional laws of marketing and communications. There's no sign on the street, no sign inside the restaurant. They done everything they can to make themselves difficult to find. And yet, every day they're full. 3 p.m. phone lines open up. By 3.30, all the seats are usually gone. You have to redial again and again trying to get through. I actually went and visited, Please Don't Tell. It took me a couple of weeks to get in and I got on on like a Tuesday night at like 6 p.m. Not the most popular time. And you might
说，“嗯，你知道，也许他们受欢迎是因为缺乏竞争，”但环顾四周，事实并非如此，对吧？那么“请不要告诉别人”是如何在喧嚣中脱颖而出的呢？如果你仔细想想，他们做了一件非常有趣的事。他们把自己变成了一个秘密。让我告诉你关于秘密的一个小秘密，好吗？想想上次有人告诉你某事并叮嘱你千万不要告诉别人的情景。如果你仔细想想，你用这个信息做的第一件事是什么？嗯，你可能告诉了别人。为什么？因为掌握了现在不是每个人都知道的信息，会让你看起来很聪明，让你显得消息灵通。它赋予了你我所谓的社交货币。所以这不仅仅关于秘密，对吧？所以你可能会说：“好吧，
say, well, you know, maybe they're popular because it's lack of competition, but look around. That's not the case, right? And so what did please don't tell do to cut through the clutter? And if you think about it, they did something really interesting. They made themselves a secret. And let me tell you a little secret about secrets, right? Think about the last time that someone told you something and they told you not to tell anyone else. And if you think about it, what's the first thing you did with that information? Well, you probably told someone. Why? Because having access to information that now everyone else has makes you look smart and makes you look in the know. It gives you what I'll call social currency. So it's not just secrets, right? So you might say, okay, well,
我明白了。人们喜欢分享秘密。”但其中有一个更根本的东西，那就是人们喜欢分享能让自己看起来不错的东西，对吧？一件事情让人看起来越好，他们就越倾向于分享它；而一件事情让人看起来越糟，他们就越不倾向于分享。如果你仔细想想，对吧？你的孩子在学校得了 A，他们可能会非常乐意告诉所有人。如果他们得了个 B 减或 C，他们可能就不太愿意谈论这事了。你打高尔夫球打得很好，你会谈论它；但如果打得很糟，也许你就没那么想谈了。你买到了一款别人都没有或者所有人都在渴望的限量版产品，也许你会谈论它。你在办公室没有得到晋升，也许你就没那么想谈论它。
I get it. People like sharing secrets. But there's something much more fundamental there, which is people like sharing things that make them look good, right? The better something makes people look, the more like they are to share it. And the worse something makes people look, the less like are to share. If you think about it, right, your kid gets an A in school, they might be very happy to tell everyone. If they get a B minus or a C, they might be less likely to talk about it. You do really well playing a round of golf. You talk about it, but you do badly. Maybe you're less likely to talk about it. You get some limited edition product that nobody else has or everybody else wants. Maybe you talk about it. You don't get, you know, a promotion at the office. Maybe you're less likely to talk about it.
因此，我们在自己身上发生的事情中进行挑选，分享那些让我们看起来光鲜的事情，并避免分享那些让我们看起来糟糕的事情。如果你在网上观察，社交媒体上的大多数帖子往往都是积极的。嘿，看我。我，你知道的，我见到名人了。看我，我买新车了。看我，我在度假。
And so we pick and choose among the things that happened to us, sharing the ones that make us look good and avoiding sharing the ones that make us look bad. If you look online, most posts on social media tend to be positive. Hey, look at me. I'm, you know, I met a celebrity. Look at me. I got a new car. Look at me. I'm on vacation.
很少有人发照片说：“嘿，看我。我在办公室处理 Excel 表格呢。来看看 C 列。”你知道的，我们大多数人在办公室处理 Excel 表格花的时间远远多于度假的时间，然而我们分享的是度假照片而不是 Excel 表格的内容，因为前者能让我们看起来更好。因此，从某种意义上说，我们在构成我们生活的各种选择中进行挑选，而我们分享事物的一个原因就是因为它能让我们看起来很好。如果某事能让我们看起来更好，我们就分享它；
Very few people post photos saying, you know, hey, look at me. I'm at the office working on Excel spreadsheet. You know, check out column C. most of us spend a lot more time working on an Excel spreadsheet at the office than we do on vacation, yet we share the vacation photos and not the Excel spreadsheet stuff because it makes us look better. And so in some sense, we pick and choose among the set of options that is our life. And one reason we share things is because it makes us look good. If something makes us look better, we share it.
如果它让我们看起来没那么好，我们就不分享。所以思考那些产生影响的各种事物是非常有趣的。比如想想常旅客飞行计划，人们喜欢为此夸耀；想想某个新艺术家推出了音乐专辑，人们喜欢谈论它；想想人们可能掌握的信息，无论是关于即将到来的暴风雪，还是关于获得某种并非所有人都能享有的产品。我们越能接触到那些能让我们看起来聪明、特别、消息灵通且并非所有人都有的东西，我们就越倾向于谈论和分享它，无论这是一个秘密、仅仅是一个酷炫的产品还是一个有趣的观点。人们喜欢走在时代前沿，但从某种意义上说，只有当别人知道你拥有这种地位时，地位才有价值。因此，获得地位的一种方式就是谈论某些事情，对吧？人们并不在乎赋予他们常旅客身份的航空公司，但谈论他们身份的唯一方法就是提及这家航空公司，
If it makes us look less good, we don't. And so it's really interesting to think about the range of things that impact. So think about frequent flyer status, and people love bragging about that. Think about, you know, a new artist has a music album out and people love talking about it. Think about information that people might have, whether it's about an impending snowstorm or, you know, access to a product that not everyone else does. The more we have access to something that makes us look smart, special in the know that not everyone else has, the more likely we are to talk about and share it, whether it's a secret, whether it's just a cool product or an interesting idea, people love being ahead of the curve, but status is only good in some sense if other people know that you have it. And so one way to get status is to talk about something, right? People don't care about the airline that gives them frequent flyer status, but the only way to talk about their status is to mention the airline,
而航空公司也就顺理成章地得到了曝光。所以，无论是聪明的品牌和组织，还是想要让其他人谈论创意的聪明人，一个非常有力的问题是：“我们怎样才能让那个受众群体产生内部人士的感觉呢？”通常我们考虑很多关于我们自己的事情，对吧？甚至作为研究人员，我们发表了一些优秀的研究，想把它公之于众。我们想了很多它出现在 LinkedIn 上时会让我看起来怎么样。但我们很少去考虑：“如果读者把这件事讲给别人听，读到它的人会看起来怎么样？”
and that gets to come along for the ride. And so, you know, whether it's smart brands and organizations or smart people who want to get others to talk about ideas, One really powerful question is, well, how can we make that audience feel like insiders? Often we think a lot about ourselves, right? Even as researchers, we publish some great research who want to put it out there. We think a lot about how's it going to make me look when it shows up on LinkedIn. But we think a lot less about, well, how is it going to make someone who reads about it look if they talk about it to someone else?
因为这让他们看起来越好，他们就越有可能将其传递下去。我们分享事物的另一个原因是因为其中包含一个故事。我的意思是，我们希望人们对我们与他们分享的东西产生情感共鸣，因为我们自己就深有同感。我只是想知道，是什么让故事成为如此强大的载体？是的，你提到了两个词。你既提到了情感（框架中的 E），又提到了最后一个 S——故事。所以也许我们可以逐一讨论。就情感而言，你知道，我想我们都见过在线病毒式传播的内容或人们在线下分享的充满情感的故事。你看 YouTube，例如，你可能会说：“哇，YouTube 上有很多搞笑视频。”你看社交媒体上愤怒的政治咆哮，你可能会说那里也有很多这类内容。所以你可能会说：“好吧，也许任何情感都会被传播。人们越在意，分享得就越多。”事实上，确实有一些数据表明情感会驱动分享，任何情感都能增加人们分享的概率。你知道，有一些非常棒的早期研究表明，人们会在日常生活中分享许多发生在他们身上的情感事件，无论是为了
Because the better it's going to make them look, the more likely they're going to be to pass it on. One other part of why we share things is that there's a story. I mean, we want people to, you know, be emotionally involved in the thing that we're sharing with them because we are. And I'm just wondering, what makes stories such a powerful vehicle? Yeah, and you mentioned two words there. You talked both about emotion, the E in the framework, and the last S, the stories. And so maybe we'll take them in turn. In terms of emotion, you know, I think we've all seen examples of content that goes viral online or stories people share offline that have a lot of emotion. You know, you look at YouTube, for example, you might say, wow, there's lots of funny videos on YouTube. And you look at angry political rants on social media, and you might say there's a lot of things there as well. And so you might say, well, hey, maybe any emotion gets shared. You know, the more people care, the more they share. And indeed, there is some data suggesting that emotions drive sharing, that any emotion can increase the chance that people share. You know, there's some very nice old work showing that, you know, people share many of
与社交圈中的其他人建立纽带，还是为了宣泄他们对某事的不满，或者是为了帮助弄清楚他们的感受，对吧？他们是悲伤还是愤怒？因此，分享这些情感可以帮助人们自己弄清楚他们到底在感受什么。但我们想知道：“好吧，所有情感被分享的概率都是一样的，还是某些情感比其他情感更有可能被分享？”你可能会说：“好吧，也许人们分享积极的情感，而避免分享消极的情感。”这在直觉上是有道理的。但正如我们刚才所讨论的，有许多消极事物被分享的优秀例子，对吧？你看看那些消极愤怒的政治咆哮，或者有一个叫做 Dell hell 的网站，人们在上面分享关于戴尔的糟糕客户服务体验。因此，肯定也有很多消极事物得到了广泛关注。那么，所有的情感都会被分享吗？还是有些比其他的分享得更多？几年前，我们确实以实证方式检验了这个问题。凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katie Milkman）和我写了一篇论文，我们基本上研究了《纽约时报》六个月的文章。该纸媒在那段时期内撰写的一切内容，从头版新闻和体育到时尚和政治内容，报纸上的数千篇文章。其中一些文章进入了所谓的“最多邮件发送列表”，即被高度分享的文章列表，而大多数则没有。所以一个问题
the emotional things that happen to them on a daily basis, whether it's to, you know, build bonds with social others or whether it's to vent about something they're upset about. or whether it's to help sort of figure out what they're feeling, right? Are they sad or are they angry? And so sharing those emotions can help people themselves figure out what it is their feeling. But we wondered, okay, well, are all emotions equally likely to get shared or are some emotions more likely than others? And you might say, well, maybe people share positive emotions and they avoid sharing negative ones. And that intuitively makes sense. But as we've just talked about, there are good examples of negative stuff being shared, right? You look at negative angry political rants or there's a
是为什么？某些文章的什么特点使它们更有可能进入“最多邮件发送列表”？让我们谨慎一点，对吧？原因之一可能仅仅是因为它们被置顶推荐了。例如，出现在主页顶部的文章可能比出现在主页底部的文章被更多的人阅读。所以也许这仅仅是因为这些文章被推荐了。因此，我们对此进行了控制。你可能还会说：“好吧，也许是因为作者有多出名，对吧？”如果一个非常著名的政治家或音乐家写了一篇文章，这往往会被大量分享。
website called Dell hell where people share negative customer service experiences with Dell. And so there's certainly some negative things that also get a lot of attention. And so to all emotions get shared or some shared more than others? And so we actually examined this question empirically a few years ago. Katie Milkman and I did a paper where we looked at basically six months of New York Times articles. Everything written over that period by the paper, everything from front page news and sports to style and political stuff, you know, thousands of articles in the newspaper. Some of those articles make what's called the most emailed list, which is the list of articles that are highly shared and most don't. And so one question
而如果普通的张三和李四写了文章，则不会。所以我们对此进行了控制。可能是因为报纸的某些版块比其他版块分享得更多，因为它们被阅读得更多，或者因为人们对它们给予了更多关注。我们也对此进行了控制。但我们真正感兴趣的是我们开始时提出的那个问题，也就是情感。因此，我们收集了所有这些文章，首先我们测量了它们唤起的情感量。它们唤起了更多的情感还是更少的情感？
is why? What about some articles made them to be more like to make the most emailed list? And let's be careful, right? One reason could just be their featured. An article that appears on the top of the homepage, for example, probably gets read by more people. and one that appears on the bottom of the homepage, potentially. And so maybe it's just the articles that are featured. And so we controlled for that. You might also say, well, maybe it's how famous the author is, right? Maybe if a really famous politician or musician writes an article, that gets shared a lot.
我们还使用杰米·佩内贝克（Jamie Pennebaker）出色的语言查询和单词计数工具（Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count），通过测量这些文章的积极性或消极性，来检验它们是唤起了积极情感还是消极情感。果不其然，顺便说一句，我们发现更具情感色彩的内容更有可能进入“最多邮件发送列表”。事实证明，正如我们之前讨论的那样，积极情感比消极情感分享得更多。但我们没有止步于此。我们还深入研究了具体的情感，对吧？悲伤和愤怒都是消极情感。但我们想知道，这些情感被分享的倾向可能存在一些差异。果不其然，当我们观察数据时，我们发现了一些有趣的事情。并不是所有消极情感都会减少分享。事实上，虽然某些消极情感（如悲伤）会减少分享，但其他消极情感（如愤怒）却产生了截然相反的效果，对吧？愤怒实际上增加了文章进入最多邮件发送列表的可能性。因此，我们开始自问的一个问题是为什么，对吧？
And if regular, you know, Joe's and Jane's write articles, it doesn't. So we controlled for that. It might be that certain sections of the paper get shared more than others because they're read more or because people pay more attention to them. And we controlled for that as well. But what we were really interested in is that question we started with, which is emotion. And so we took all these articles, and first we measured the amount of emotion they evoked. Did they evoke more emotion or less emotion?
是什么区分了愤怒和悲伤，这又将如何影响分享？我们一开始并不确定。然后我们在内容中注意到了一些令人惊讶的事情，那就是科学文章实际上做得相当不错。作为一名科学家，我发现这相当令人鼓舞。但你看看它们，它们并不总是受众最广的作品，对吧？所以，你知道，关于“鹿的视觉以及如何制作伪装服使鹿看不到它们”的问题，或者“宇宙的最深处以及是否存在额外的行星和星系”的问题，这些在某种程度上是很小众的事情，但它们却获得了大量的关注。我们想知道为什么。我们意识到，许多这类文章唤起了一种人们经常描述为
We also examined whether they evoked positive emotions or negative motions using Jamie Pennebaker's great linguistic inquiry and word count, measuring the positivity or the negativity of those articles. And sure enough, by the way, we found that more emotional content was more likely to make the most emailed list. It turned out, consisted with what we kind of talked about already, that positive emotion was shared more than negative emotion. But we didn't stop there. We dug into specific emotions as well, right? Both sadness and anger are negative emotions. But we wondered if there might be some differences in how like those emotions are to be shared. And sure enough, when we looked at the data, we found something interesting. It wasn't that all negative emotions decreased sharing. In fact, while some negative emotions like sadness decreased sharing, other negative emotions like anger, anger had the exact opposite effect, right? Anger actually increased the likelihood that articles were to make the most email list. And so one question we already started asking ourselves is why, right?
敬畏（awe）的情感，对吧？这种灵感的概念，在某种程度上拓宽了一个人的视野。我们说：“好吧，很有意思。”所以我们在模型中加入了敬畏。果不其然，内容唤起的敬畏感越多，它被分享的可能性就越大。但这仍然没有解释愤怒和悲伤之间的区别。所以我们试图说：“好吧，敬畏有什么共同点呢？”它与愤怒一起增加了分享。在某些方面，它们截然不同，对吧？敬畏是一种积极情感，愤怒是一种消极情感。但尽管它们的效价（valence）不同，它们在另一个不同的潜在底层维度上却有很多共同点，那就是它们唤起的生理唤醒（physiological arousal）程度。想想如果你在树林里露营，听到一个声音，你的战斗或逃跑反应
What separates anger and sadness and how might that differentiate sharing? We weren't sure right away. And then we noticed something kind of surprising in the content, which is that science articles were actually doing pretty well. And as a scientist myself, I found that pretty heartening. But you look at them and they're not always the broadest pieces, right? So, you know, a question about, like, dear vision and how camouflaged clothes can be made so that, you know, deer can't see them, or, you know, deepest recesses of the universe and whether there are additional planets and stars, kind of things that are niche in some ways, but we're getting a lot of attention. And we wondered why. And what we realized is that many of these articles evoked in emotion, people often describe as
就会被触发，你知道，你准备好从任何可能的东西中逃跑了；或者想想当你的球队输掉一场重要比赛时会发生什么，你很愤怒，你想摔东西。情感通常以生理唤醒为特征，无论你是被点燃并准备采取行动，还是能量耗尽并处于不活跃状态。我们发现，这不仅仅取决于情感是积极的还是消极的。任何高唤醒度的情感，无论是积极的还是消极的，都会增加分享。愤怒，对吧，会激发我们采取行动。我们可以采取的行动之一就是分享。悲伤会削弱我们的精力。我们不想做太多事情，对吧？当你想到悲伤时，你会想吃一大碗通心粉配奶酪或冰淇淋（取决于你的喜好），穿上运动衫，然后，你知道的，感到舒适惬意。你
awe, right? This notion of inspiration, kind of widening one's perspective. And we said, okay, interesting. So we included awe on the model. Sure enough, the more awe content evoked, the more like it was B2D be shared. But that still didn't explain the difference between anger and sadness. And so we were trying to say, okay, well, what does awe have in common? It increases sharing with anger. In some ways, they're pretty different, right? Aw is a positive emotion. Anger is a negative emotion. But even though their difference in their valence, they actually have a lot in common on another different underlying dimension, which is the amount of physiological arousal they evoke. Think about if you're camping in the woods and you hear a noise, your fight or flight response
不想做太多事情。事实证明，任何这些能激发我们采取行动的情感都会鼓励我们分享，如果你仔细想想，这其实非常有趣，因为你可能会说：“好吧，你知道，搞笑的 YouTube 视频与愤怒的政治咆哮完全不同。”在某些方面，它们确实完全不同。一个是积极情感，一个是消极情感。你知道，一个让我们笑，一个让我们沮丧。但它们实际上有很多共同点，那就是这两者都是高唤醒度的。幽默是一种高唤醒度的情感，愤怒也是一种高唤醒度的情感。我认为这对于有兴趣让创意、产品或服务流行的个人来说，具有一些非常重要的启示。
goes off, you know, you're ready to run away from whatever it might be, or think about what happens when your team loses a big game, you're angry, you want to throw something. Emotions are often characterized by physiological arousal, whether you're fired up and ready to take action or whether you're powered down and deactivated. And what we found is it's not just about whether emotions are positive or negative. Any high arousal motion, whether positive or negative, increased sharing. Anger, right, fires us up to take action. And one of those actions we can take is sharing. Sadness powers us down. We don't want to do very much, right? When you think about being sad, you want to eat a big bowl of macaroni and cheese or ice cream, depending on your preferences, put on a sweatshirt and, you know, sort of be cozy. You
你知道，通常我们认为，只要我们让人感到美好、快乐、积极，他们就会把东西传递下去。但这还不够，对吧？满足感是一种积极情感。感到满足感觉相当不错。但当你走出健身课或瑜伽课时，你感觉相当不错，但你并不想做太多事情。你不会去分享某事，
don't want to do very much. And so it turns out any of these emotions that fire us up to take action encourage us to share, which is actually pretty interesting if you think about it because you might say, well, okay, you know, funny YouTube videos are completely different than angry political rants. And in some ways, they are completely different. One is a positive emotion. One is a negative emotion. You know, one makes us laugh. One makes us frustrated. But they actually have a lot in common, which is that both of those things are high arousal. Humor is a high arousal emotion. And anger is a high arousal emotion. And I think this has some pretty important takeaways for individuals that are interested in getting ideas to catch on or products or services.
你不会把它传递下去，因为你感到的是能量消退而不是被激活。所以在积极方面，仅仅让人们感觉良好是不够的。我们必须让他们感受到那种高唤醒度的情感。我们必须激发他们采取行动，让他们想要传递某些东西。而在消极方面，当然，我们不想让人们感受到消极情感，但利用他们可能已经感受到的消极情感，是鼓励他们分享的好方法，无论是与政治事业相关，还是与他们在某个特定领域遇到的问题、他们希望有所不同的问题相关。通过理解他们已经感受到的那些消极情感——那些他们已经感受到的高唤醒度消极情感，我们可以鼓励他们传递各种各样的东西。
You know, often we think about, okay, as long as we make people feel good, happy, positive, they'll pass stuff on. But it's not enough, right? Contentment is a positive emotion. It feels pretty good to be content. But when you walk out of an exercise class or a yoga class, you feel pretty good, but you don't want to do very much. You're not going to share something. you're not going to pass it on because you feel deactivated rather than activated. And so on the positive side, it's not just enough to make people feel good. We've got to make them feel that high arousal of them. We've got to fire them up to take action to want to pass something on. And on the negative side, you know, sure, we don't want to make people feel negative emotions, but taking advantage of the negative emotions they may already feel can be a great way to encourage them to share, whether it's related to a political cause or an issue they have in a certain space, a problem. they wish was different. By understanding those negative emotions they're already feeling, those high
在人们分享事物的六个原因（也就是你所说的“步骤”）中，它们的价值都一样吗，还是其中一个比其他更具影响力？这在某种程度上确实取决于具体情况。如果你看看那些经常获得大量关注、也就是所谓在网络上“病毒式传播”的事物，通常它们至少有一个成分做得非常好——这六个成分中的一个，但这并不意味着必须具备全部六个。
arousal negative emotions they're already feeling, we can encourage them to pass all sorts of things on. Out of the six reasons that people share things, the steps, as you call them, are they all of equal value or does one hold sway over another? You know, it really depends on the situation to some degree. And if you look at things that often get a lot of attention, you know, quote-unquote go viral around the web, often they have at least one ingredient that they do very well on, one of the six, but it's not necessarily to have all six.
事物很少能具备全部六个。例如，我们对线上与线下口碑进行了分析，观察消费者描述为更有趣的品牌，以及人们描述为没那么有趣的产品、服务和品牌，对吧？所以，你知道，得罪了，我不知道，比方说，橡皮擦公司，橡皮擦可能不是人们能想到的最有趣的产品和服务，而高科技产品往往更有趣一些。因此，我们研究了有趣的产品、品牌和服务是否比无聊的产品、品牌和服务
Rarely do things have all six. We did an analysis, for example, of online versus offline word of mouth, looking at brands that consumers would describe as more interesting and products and services and brands that people would describe as less interesting, right? So, you know, no offense to, I don't know, let's say, eraser companies, but erasers probably aren't the most interesting product and service people think of, whereas high-tech products tend to be a little bit more interesting. And so we looked at whether interesting products and brands and services get talked about more
获得更多的谈论。我们发现的结果其实让我们有点惊讶。因此，有线上和线下口碑的数据。我们发现，果不其然，如果你在网上观察，有趣的东西往往比无聊的东西获得更多的谈论。平均而言，有趣的产品和服务往往比无聊的产品和服务获得更多的谈论。然而，我们在线下也进行了同样的分析，观察了线下口碑。在那里我们发现其实并没有什么影响。有趣的产品或服务并没有比不那么有趣的产品或服务获得更多的谈论。
than boring ones. And what we found actually surprised us a little bit. So there's data both on online and offline word of, mouth. And we found that sure enough, if you look online, interesting stuff tends to get talked about more than boring stuff. Interesting products and services on average tend to get talked about more than boring products and services on average. And so we did that same analysis though offline, looking at offline a word of mouth. And there we found there was actually no effect. Interesting products or services didn't get talked about more than less interesting ones.
当我们仔细思考时，我们意识到线上和线下分享之间存在某种差异，对吧？所以在线分享通常是你有选择的。我是想分享某事还是不分享？或者，我在谈论某事，我可以分享任何东西。我要挑选什么来分享？所以通常情况下，问题不是我想不想分享某事，而是它是否超过了一个门槛？它是否足够好以至于可以分享？所以在这些情况下，我可能会说：“好吧，让我谈谈我做过的非常有趣的事情，而不是无聊的事情。”另一方面，线下口碑通常要同步得多，对吧？别人问我们一个问题，我们必须填补对话的空间。我们必须说点什么，而且我们必须相对较快地说点什么。
And when we thought about it, we realized there's a sort of a difference between kind of online and offline sharing, right? So online sharing is often you have a choice. Do I want to share something or not? Or, you know, I'm talking about something I could share anything. What am I going to pick to share about? And so it's often, the question is not do I want to share something, but is it above a threshold? Is it good enough to share? And so in those situations, I might say, well, let me talk about the really interesting thing I did and not the boring one. Offline word of mouth, on the other hand, is often much more synchronous, right? Someone asks us a question, and we have to fill in that conversational space. We have to say something, and we have to say something relatively quickly.
所以我们不一定有时间去思考我能谈论或分享的最有趣的事情是什么。它往往更多地关于当下最显眼的事情，对吧？当我被问到一个问题或正在进行对话时，我此刻在想什么？我能想到的最相关的事情是什么？让我谈谈那个。这实际上涉及的与其说是 S（社交货币），不如说是 T（诱因），对吧？所以诱因完全关乎“脑海中最显眼，嘴边最容易脱口而出”（top of mind means tip of tongue）。我们越倾向于思考某事，我们就越倾向于谈论和分享它。如果你观察，例如，许多人谈论天气。你可能会说（撇开冬天的天气不谈，冬天的天气显然非常重要，
And so we don't necessarily have time to think about what's the most interesting thing I could talk about or share. It tends to be a little bit more about what's top of mind, right? What am I thinking about right now when you ask a question or when I'm having a conversation? What's the most relevant thing I can think of? Let me talk about that. And that really gets into less the S, that's social currency and more the T, the triggers, right? So triggers is all about top of mind means tip of tongue. The more likely we're to be thinking about something, the more likely we are to talk about and share it. If you look, for example, you know, many people talk about the weather. And you might say, you know, winter weather aside, which is obviously very important, you know,
比如学校停课和服装之类的事情），但为什么人们如此频繁地谈论天气？这不是发生在我们身上最有趣的事情，但它是最显眼的。这是我们身边一直存在的东西。所以问题不仅在于：我们喜欢某事吗？它让我们看起来好看吗？或者它唤起了高唤醒度的情感吗？而在于：我们在想它吗？如果我们没有在想某事，我们就真的不太可能会谈论它。因此，我认为这也带来了一些有趣的启示，对吧？想想什么是诱因，从某种意义上说，它是环境中让人想起某事的提醒，是环境中促使我们去想一件事的线索，而这件事我们原本并没有在想。所以如果我说“花生酱和”，例如，
if schools are clothing and the like, but, you know, why do people talk so often about the weather? It's not the most interesting thing that happens to us, but it is top of mind. It is something that's around us all the time. And so the question isn't just, you know, do we like something? Does it make us look good? Or does it evoke high arousal emotions? But are we thinking about it? If we're not thinking about something, it's really unlikely that we'll talk about it. And so this also, I think, has some interesting implications, right? You think about what a trigger is, it's in some sense a reminder in the environment to think about something, a cue in the environment that makes us think about something we weren't thinking about already. So if I said peanut butter and, for example,
你的许多听众可能会想到“果冻”，或者如果我说“朗姆酒”，他们可能会想到“可口可乐”。从某种意义上说，它们是环境中的提醒，鼓励我们去想某些事情。因此，我们越希望别人谈论或分享与我们、我们的产品、我们的服务或想法相关的事情，我们就越需要思考：环境中会有哪些诱因或线索能让他们谈论此事？例如，糖果品牌奇巧（Kit Kat）有一个著名的广告活动，它在提升销量方面做得非常出色，这并不是因为它改变了人们对这个品牌的喜爱程度，而是因为它让人们更频繁地想到这个品牌。它将 Kit Kat 和咖啡联系在了一起。喝杯咖啡休息一下，来一块 Kit Kat；想到咖啡，就想到 Kit Kat。咖啡和
many of your listeners would probably think of jelly, or if I said rum and they might think of Coke. In some sense, they're environmental reminders that encourage us to think about something. And so the more we want someone to talk about or share, something that relates to us, our product, our service, or idea, the more we need to think about, well, what are those triggers or cues in the environment that are going to make them talk about it? There's a famous campaign from the Candy Bar Kit Kat, for example, that did a great job of boosting sales, not because it changed how much people liked the brand, but it just made them think about it more often. It linked Kit Kat and coffee. Having a coffee break, have a Kit Kat, thinking about coffee, think about Kit Kat. Coffee and
Kit Kat，Kit Kat 和咖啡，永远的最佳拍档。那个广告活动让人们更经常地想到 Kit Kat，因为很多人喝咖啡，而且他们喝得非常频繁。于是，咖啡成为了一个能让人联想起该品牌的诱因。它越是占据人们的心智（top of mind），就越容易脱口而出（tip of tongue）。我们将进行短暂的休息。休息回来后，我将与伯格博士探讨社交媒体以及它是否改变了我们的分享内容。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠开始。是时候用 NextGrill 四燃烧器燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
Kit Kat, Kit Kat and coffee, best friends forever. That campaign made people think more often about Kit Kat because lots of people drink coffee and they drink it really frequently. And so now coffee became a trigger to bring the brand to mind. And the more it was top of mind, the more it was Tate of Tom. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Berger about social media and whether it has changed what we share. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.
整个季节都用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫（West Grove）七件套户外餐桌椅进行招待，只需 499 美元。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，家得宝保证为您提供超低价格。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用免责条款。详情请访问 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路的台阶。我们省了多少？够了。
This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed, at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Price is invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
够去迷路了！或者你可以预订希爾頓（Hilton）的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房，距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要的是省钱，而不是惊吓。
Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises.
住哪里至关重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦常在。如果我可以转换一下话题，谈谈你十多年前写的书《疯传》（Contagious），我认为这本书在许多方面都非常有远见。这以我们
It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. If I could switch gears for a minute and talk about the book Contagious that you wrote more than a decade ago, which I think was in many ways, you know, very almost prescient. This is taken off in ways that we
从未想象过的方式腾飞了。不过我只是想知道，自那以后社交媒体格局已经发生了变化，出现了更多平台，而且我们有了将各种内容推送给我们的 AI 算法。这是否改变了我们分享的信息类型？是的，这是一个很好的问题。而且，我认为在思考这个问题时，不仅要看现在，还要看过去，对吧？首先，当我们想到口碑和所谓的病毒式传播时，很容易只想到线上，只想到社交媒体。事实上，在当今时代，社交媒体确实推动了相当一部分分享。但据估计，很大一部分口碑甚至可能绝大部分口碑，
could never have imagined. I'm just wondering, though, that the social media landscape has changed since then, and there are more platforms, and we've got these AI algorithms that are pushing all kinds of things to us. Is that changed the types of information that we're sharing? Yeah, that's a great question. And, you know, I think it's important, though, when thinking about that question, to not just look at the now, but look at the past as well, right? So first, it's really easy when we think about word of mouth and things going viral per se, to think online, to think about social media. And indeed, in today's day and age, social media drives a good bit of sharing. But much word of mouth, by some estimates, is not even potentially most word of mouth,
仍然是线下的。它仍然是面对面的。此外，口碑的第一个例证并非在社交媒体出现时才诞生。那是在人们开始交流的时候，对吧？很可能是一个原始人或一个女性原始人告诉另一个原始人：“别吃那个。有毒。”口碑自古以来就存在。
is still offline. It's still face to face. And further, you know, the first example of word of mouth didn't happen when social media came around. It was when people started communicating, right? It was one caveman probably, or one cavewoman telling another, you know, don't eat that. It's poisonous. Word of mouth has been around forever.
社交媒体改变了口碑吗？是的，在某些方面它让分享变得更快、更容易，能够以更高的速度与更多人分享。过去，如果你把某件事告诉你的邻居，而他们又告诉了另一个人，另一个人又告诉了别人，信息扩散需要一段时间。在当今时代，如果你在社交媒体上广播某些东西，很多人可以非常快地看到它，甚至跨越不同的地理区域。因此，它有更广泛传播的机会。
Has social media changed word of mouth? Yes, in some ways it's made it faster and easier to share things with more people more quickly. It used to be that if you told your neighbor something and they told another person, they told another person, it would take a while for it to diffuse. In today's day and age, if you broadcast something on social media, lots of people can see it very quickly, even across different geographies. And so it has the opportunity to spread more broadly. more quickly. But that's not the only way that things get shared. I actually, it's funny enough,
传播得更快。但这并不是事物被分享的唯一方式。我实际上，说来有趣，
you know, some people say, oh, you know, you must have gotten started studying this by studying social media. I actually got started in this area by studying rumors and urban legends. So I was an undergraduate at Stanford University. I read this book. My grandmother recommended it called the tipping point, which some of you may remember, you know, great book. And I decided I was interested in studying that sort of stuff. And I was looking for an advisor to work with. And there was this guy who had just joined Stanford in the business school. His name was Chip Heath. And he was interested in what makes urban legends get shared. And it's hard to remember now. But, you know, back in the late 1990s, early 2000s, nobody was interested in rumors and urban legends, right? Everyone was like,
你知道的，有些人会说，哦，你知道，你开始研究这个肯定是通过研究社交媒体。其实我进入这个领域是从研究谣言和都市传说开始的。当时我在斯坦福大学读本科，读了这本书，我的祖母推荐的，叫《引爆点》，你们中的一些人可能还记得，一本很棒的书。我决定我有兴趣研究这类东西，当时我正在寻找一个合作的导师。有个人刚刚加入斯坦福商学院，他的名字叫奇普·希思（Chip Heath）。他对是什么让都市传说得以传播很感兴趣。现在很难记起来了，但是，你知道，在20世纪90年代末、2000年代初，没有人对谣言和都市传说感兴趣，对吧？每个人都觉得，
oh, rumors in urban legends are kids stuff. Who cares? You know, nobody shares false information. I was the, I was the worst person to have at a party, right? Because someone would share an urban legend and I'd say, no, no, it's not real. That's this thing that, you know, often circulates. But it turns out the drivers that shape rumors and urban legends getting shared are the same things that shape whether we talk about products or services or other sorts of ideas. And so, sure, you know, is social media on the margins changing sharing? In some ways it is, but the platforms come and go, right? You know, if we if we looked in the early 2000s, right, you might have said, what drives sharing, MySpace.
哦，谣言和都市传说都是小孩子的把戏。谁在乎呢？你知道的，没有人会传播虚假信息。我是那种在派对上最不受欢迎的人，对吧？因为有人会分享一个都市传说，然后我会说，不，不，这不是真的。这只是一种，你知道的，经常流传的东西。但事实证明，塑造谣言和都市传说得以传播的驱动因素，与塑造我们是否谈论产品、服务或其他类型观点的因素是相同的。所以，当然，你知道的，社交媒体在边缘上改变了分享吗？在某些方面确实如此，但平台总是来来去去，对吧？你知道，如果我们回顾2000年代初，你可能会说，是什么在推动分享？MySpace。
It's all about MySpace. And then it was Foursquare. And then it was Facebook. And the list goes on and on of new technologies that pop up, that take a chunk of the online sharing. And they still do. And they will in the future. But I think much, if not most of sharing, is still offline.
全都是关于MySpace的。然后是Foursquare。然后是Facebook。这种涌现出来的新技术名单长又长，它们占据了在线分享的一大块。它们现在依然如此，将来也会如此。但我认为，很大一部分（如果不是绝大多数的话）分享仍然是离线的。
And the psychological drivers of why we share aren't necessarily different, right? You know, in the 1950s and 60s, people still cared about looking good to others. way they shared might have been different. There was no social media. And so it was, you know, in the boardroom or at a dinner party or on the phone. But that underlying motivation was the same. Similarly, you know, that idea of triggers, top of mind, tip of tongue, that's not new. People, accessibility, right? The psychology of cognitive accessibility, it's been studied for decades at this point. And so all we're doing here is we're saying, well, hey, this really drives sharing this domain that hasn't been thought about as much. And so, sure, on the margins, does social change sharing? Sure, it shifts
而且我们分享的心理驱动因素并没有本质上的不同，对吧？你知道，在20世纪50年代和60年代，人们仍然在意自己在别人眼中的良好形象。他们分享的方式可能有所不同。当时没有社交媒体，所以分享发生在董事会、晚宴派对或电话里。但那种潜在的动机是一样的。同样地，你知道，触发因素、常驻脑海、话到嘴边这些概念并不是新鲜事。人们的易得性，对吧？认知易得性的心理学，到目前为止已经被研究了几十年。所以我们在这里所做的一切，都是在说，嘿，这确实推动了在这个领域的分享，而这个领域之前并没有受到那么多关注。所以，当然，在边缘上，社会变化会改变分享吗？当然，它会稍微改变
things a little bit. And sure, there are differences between online and offline sharing. Just like, by the way, there are differences between sharing on different platforms based on the rules and approaches of those platforms. But I think the more we understand the psychology, rather than just focusing on the technology, the more insightful and correct we can be, right? Even think about sharing on quote-unquote social media. There are different ways to do it. I can broadcast something to all my followers, or I can choose to narrowcast it to just one or a couple people. And we've done work that finds, for example, that difference, both of them are online, both are in some sense sharing on social media, but that shapes the kind of things that we share.
一些事情。而且，线上分享和线下分享之间确实存在差异。就像，顺便说一句，根据不同平台的规则和方法，在不同平台上分享也存在差异。但我认为，我们对心理学的理解越多，而不是只关注技术，我们就越能深刻和正确，对吧？甚至想想在所谓的社交媒体上的分享。有不同的方式可以做到这一点。我可以向我所有的粉丝广播某事，或者我可以选择将其窄播给一个人或几个人。我们做过研究发现，例如，这种差异——两者都在线上，在某种意义上都是在社交媒体上分享——但它塑造了我们分享的内容。
When we share to a broad group, when we broadcast, we tend to focus on ourselves, whereas when we narrowcast, we're more likely to think about our audience. We're less like to be egocentric. And so we're more likely to share things that are useful or valuable to them. And so that's less about the technology per se and more about the psychology of social transmission. Does your research offer any ideas on how to fight viral misinformation? Yeah, you know, this is a question I've thought about a lot. It's disheartening to see how much misinformation goes around. I often work with nonprofits or organizations say, God, you know,
当我们向一个广泛的群体分享、当我们广播时，我们倾向于关注自己；而当我们窄播时，我们更有可能考虑我们的受众。我们不那么容易以自我为中心。因此，我们更有可能分享对他们有用或有价值的东西。所以这与其说是关于技术本身，不如说是关于社会传播的心理学。你的研究对如何打击病毒式传播的虚假信息有什么启发吗？是的，你知道，这是我思考过很多的一个问题。看到这么多虚假信息四处流传，真的很令人沮丧。我经常与非营利组织或机构合作，他们说，天哪，你知道，
why doesn't our good, valuable stuff get shared as much as the false stuff? And I often bring up an analogy where I talk about Brussels sprouts. You know, if you ask people, which is tastier, Brussels sprouts are a cheeseburger. Everyone will pick the cheeseburger. It's not that the Brussels sprouts aren't good for you. It's just the way cheeseburger's designed fits better with the way your tongue and the stomach are designed, right? It, you know, makes your brain light up. It does all these things.
为什么我们的好东西、有价值的东西没有像虚假的东西那样被广泛分享？我经常举一个类比，我谈到了抱子甘蓝。你知道，如果你问人们，哪个更好吃，是抱子甘蓝还是芝士汉堡。每个人都会选择芝士汉堡。这并不是说抱子甘蓝对你不好，只是芝士汉堡的设计方式更符合你的舌头和胃的设计方式，对吧？它让你的大脑兴奋起来。它做了所有这些事情。
It's just plain tasty. And so, you know, organizations want people to eat healthier. They say, hey, eat your fruits and vegetables. But the cheeseburgers are loring when it's late at night, when we're on the road or the tire, the cheeseburger beckons. And so what can we do if we're the Brussels sprouts? And the answer is not, I'm not saying be the cheeseburger. But what I am saying is think about how you cook the Brussels sprouts, right?
它就是单纯的好吃。所以，你知道，机构希望人们吃得更健康。他们说，嘿，吃你的水果和蔬菜。但是当夜深人行、我们在路上或者疲惫不堪时，芝士汉堡是诱人的，芝士汉堡在召唤。如果我们是抱子甘蓝，我们能做什么呢？答案不是，我不是说去做芝士汉堡。但我想说的是，想想你怎么烹饪抱子甘蓝，对吧？
When I was growing up, Brussels sprouts were like the worst thing my parents could cook. Because they would steam them. And I don't know about you, but steamed Brussels sprouts are not particularly good. And so there was a whole decade of my life where I basically boycotted Brussels sprouts. And then I moved to Philadelphia and I went to a new American restaurant and they had roasted Brussels sprouts or whatever it was, a little bit of olive oil and a little bit of salt. And someone at the table ordered them and I thought they'd be terrible and I tried one and they were delicious. And then I started eating a bunch more Brussels sprouts. And so it wasn't about, hey, taking the nutritious
在我成长的时候，抱子甘蓝就像是我父母能做的最糟糕的东西。因为他们会蒸它们。我不知道你们怎么样，但清蒸抱子甘蓝特别不好吃。所以在我生命中的整整十年里，我基本上抵制了抱子甘蓝。后来我搬到了费城，去了一家新美式餐厅，他们有烤抱子甘蓝什么的，加了一点橄榄油和一点盐。桌上的某个人点了一盘，我以为会很难吃，但我尝了一个，它们太好吃了。然后我开始吃更多的抱子甘蓝。所以这与，嘿，把有营养的
stuff and make it a cheeseburger. It was cooking it different in a way that was easy. for people to digest. And I think that's the important way to think about it, right? If we've got true, if we've got valuable, if we've got useful information, we can't just sit there and say, you know, I wish it were different, right? People are wrong. They're biased. We have to say, well, hold on, people are going to share what people are going to share. How by understanding why people share things, can I engineer my good, my truthful, my valuable stuff? So it's more like to be shared. You know, most people are sharing misinformation, aren't sharing it because they're know it's misinformation or they want to diffuse misinformation, they're sharing it for the same
东西拿来做成芝士汉堡无关。而是以一种对人们来说易于消化的人性化方式进行不同的烹饪。我认为这是思考它的重要方式，对吧？如果我们掌握了真实的、有价值的、有用的信息，我们不能只是坐在那里说，你知道，我希望情况有所不同，对吧？人们是错的。他们是有偏见的。我们必须说，好吧，等等，人们会分享他们要分享的东西。通过理解人们为什么分享事物，我如何设计我的好的、真实的、有价值的东西？这样它就更有可能被分享。你知道，大多数传播虚假信息的人，传播它并不是因为他们知道它是虚假信息，或者他们想传播虚假信息，他们传播它是出于我们刚才已经讨论过
reasons we already talked about, right? It evokes social currency. It makes them look good. It's surprising. It's novel. It makes them look like an insider. It evokes high arousal emotion, that E in the Steps framework, right? It makes them angry. It makes them excited. It inspires them. And so they pass it on not thinking about the fact that it might not be real. It's top of mind, right? Top of mind, more like a be tip of tongue, that triggers idea. the more they're thinking about it, the more like they are to pass it on. And so to fight misinformation, it's not about, you know, saying, oh, I wish things were different. It's about saying, how can I take that good stuff, that Brussels sprouts, those nutritious, valuable information,
的相同原因，对吧？它唤起了社会货币。它让他们看起来不错。它是令人惊讶的。它是新奇的。它让他们看起来像个内部人士。它唤起了高唤醒度的情绪，也就是Steps框架中的那个E，对吧？它让他们生气。它让他们兴奋。它激励了他们。所以他们传递它，却没有考虑到它可能不是真的。它是常驻脑海的，对吧？常驻脑海，更像是话到嘴边，触发了那个想法。他们对它想得越多，就越有可能将其传递下去。因此，要打击虚假信息，不是去说，哦，我希望事情有所不同。而是去说，我如何才能把好东西、抱子甘蓝、那些有营养、有价值的信息，
and cook it in a way that's easier to understand, that's easier to digest, and that's easier to transmit. I think, you know, unfortunately, both scientists and nonprofits have this thing often in common, which is they assume, look, if the stuff is good enough, it'll win. We assume that we just have good enough research, if we are good enough cause, that it will win. And unfortunately, good stuff isn't always enough. There's so many pieces of interesting research. There's so many good causes out there that people can't necessarily give their attention or their money or their shares to all of them. And so the stuff that wins is going to be the stuff that fits best with people. If we understand that science of social transmission, we can help the good, the valuable, and the, in terms of
用一种更容易理解、更容易消化、更容易传播的方式烹饪出来？我认为，不幸的是，科学家和非营利组织通常有一个共同点，那就是他们假设，看，只要东西足够好，它就会赢。我们假设只要我们有足够好的研究，如果我们是一项足够好的事业，它就会赢。但不幸的是，好东西并不总是足够的。有那么多有趣的研究。有那么多好的事业，人们不可能把他们的注意力、金钱或分享分给所有这些。所以，能胜出的东西将是最适合人们的东西。如果我们理解了社会传播的科学，我们就能帮助好的、有价值的、以及在真相方面的
truthful stuff went out. What about the role of repetition? I mean, the fact that something gets repeated over and over again to a point where people can't tell anymore whether it's true or not. You look at that? Yeah, you know, I haven't looked a lot at that specifically. There's certainly research that suggests that repetition can make some information more believable. There's also research on repetition and advertising that shows that, you know, if you hear something too many times, it gets annoying or, you know, you get bored of it or you dislike it. And you dislike it. And in certain ways. And so I think there's lots of interesting research going on, trying to encourage people to be smarter consumers of information, right, to think twice when they read something or come
好东西胜出。重复的作用是什么？我是说，某种东西被一遍又一遍地重复，直到人们分不清它是真是假的地步。你看过这个吗？是的，你知道，我没有专门针对这个做过很多研究。确实有研究表明，重复可以使某些信息更具有可信度。也有关于广告中重复的研究表明，你知道，如果你听一件事太多次，它就会变得令人讨厌，或者，你知道，你会对它感到厌烦，或者你讨厌它。并且在某些方面。所以我认为有很多有趣的研究正在进行，试图鼓励人们成为更聪明的的信息消费者，对吧，在他们阅读或遇到某些东西时三思而后行
across something. But I think the biggest thing for me is to stop treating false information and true information is completely different classes of things, right? To most people, it's just information. And so the question is, what drives people to share information in the first place? and that's where the steps can be really helpful. How is technology changing the way you do your research and the kinds of things that you're looking at? You know, that's a great question. And one of my first forays in this space
。但我认为对我和最重要的事情是停止将虚假信息和真实信息视为完全不同的两类事物，对吧？对大多数人来说，这只是信息。所以问题是，是什么促使人们首先分享信息？这就是Steps框架可以非常有用地方。技术如何改变你做研究的方式以及你所关注的事情？你知道，这真是个好问题。我在这个领域的第一次尝试之一
was this old article at this point on what Mike's online content viral where we used, you know, very basic natural language processing tool, basically a dictionary that counted the number of positive words and negative words. And in some ways when I look back at that, very rudimentary, right? You know, given the technology that's out there now, machine learning,
是一篇关于迈克在线内容如何病毒式传播的旧文章，当时我们使用了一个非常基础的自然语言处理工具，基本上是一个计算积极词汇和消极词汇数量的词典。在某些方面，当我回看那个时候，是非常基础的，对吧？考虑到现在外面的技术，机器学习，
natural language processing tools that are available that we've used in lots of follow-up projects, in some ways it was very rudimentary, but it was also very powerful. And so I think, you know, we've been so lucky to have tools like linguistic inquiry and word count to build on now. Now there are more sophisticated things out there, but that was, and still is, a great tool to begin to introduce people to these areas. But, you know, we've used lots of different tools. We've done topic modeling, for example, which extracts the main topic or themes of songs to look at what makes songs successful. We found that songs whose lyrics are more atypical from their genre tend to be more popular, tend to rise higher on the Billboard charts. So think about,
自然语言处理工具是可用的，我们在许多后续项目中都使用过，在某些方面它非常基础，但它也非常强大。所以我认为，你知道，我们非常幸运能有像语言调查和字数统计这样工具来作为基础。现在有更复杂的东西出来了，但过去是，现在依然是一个很好的工具，可以用来向人们介绍这些领域。但是，你知道，我们使用了很多不同的工具。例如，我们做了主题建模，它提取歌曲的主要主题或歌词主题，来看看是什么让歌曲成功。我们发现，歌词在其流派中更具非典型性的歌曲往往更受欢迎，在公告牌排行榜上上升得更高。所以想想，
you know, Little Naz-X and his song Old Town Road, right? It wasn't completely country and it wasn't completely hip-hop. It was sort of this weird mix of the two, and it was one of the most successful songs on Billboard ever because it was different than its genres. We've also looked at, you know, starting to look at not just language, but also vocal features or audio features or visual features. We recently did a project looking at hand gestures. One of my colleagues is Italian and, you know, people say, oh, Italians, they always talk with their hands. And so he was saying, well, you know, is that actually true? And, you know, is talking with your hands useful? And so we analyze thousands hundreds if not thousands of TED talks
你知道，Little Naz-X和他的歌《Old Town Road》，对吧？它不完全是乡村音乐，也不是完全的hip-hop。它可以说是这两者的某种奇妙混合，它是公告牌历史上最成功的歌曲之一，因为它与它的流派不同。我们还研究了，你知道，开始研究的不仅仅是语言，还有声乐特征、音频特征或视觉特征。我们最近做了一个项目，研究手势。我的一个同事是意大利人，你知道，人们说，哦，意大利人，他们说话总是手舞足蹈的。所以他在说，好吧，你知道，这真的是真的吗？而且，你知道，说话时手势有用吗？所以我们分析了成千上万，如果不是数千的话，TED演讲
and the amount of engagement they received and specifically looked at how much the speakers moved their hands. And we found that when speakers moved their hands more, their talks received more engagement. But it wasn't just that any hand movements were beneficial. Certain types of hand movements were more beneficial than others. Certain types of movements illustrate what we're saying.
以及它们收到的互动量，具体研究了演讲者手部移动的程度。我们发现，当演讲者手部移动更多时，他们的演讲会获得更多的互动。但这并不是说任何手部动作都是有益的。某些类型的手部动作比其他动作更有益。某些类型的动作说明了我们正在说的话。
If I say, you know, I caught a really big fish and you can't see my hands right now, but imagine I'm putting my hand sort of wide, to show how big the fish is, or, you know, really these are the steps to success and I move my hands in a stepwise motion. That visual illustration of what I'm talking about can help the audience understand what we're saying, whereas just scratching my nose or, you know, clapping my hands may get attention, but it's not as likely to lead to understanding. So really, you know, these tools are unlocking a variety of sources of data, whether it be textual, linguistic data, whether it be audio
如果我说，你知道，我抓了一条很大的鱼，你现在看不到我的手，但想象我把手放得很宽，来展示鱼有多大，或者，你知道，这真的是通往成功的步骤，我以阶梯式的动作移动我的手。这种对我所谈论内容的视觉说明可以帮助观众理解我们在说什么，而只是挠鼻子或者，你知道，拍手可能会引起注意，但它不太可能带来理解。所以真的，你知道，这些工具正在解锁各种数据源，无论是文本、语言数据，无论是音频
features and how quickly we speak or, you know, whether we pause in between utterances or or visual features, right? Things like the way we move our hands or facial expressions or body language, all of these things can really help us understand how to communicate more effectively and why products, services, and ideas catch on. So to wrap up, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're still trying to answer? You know, I think similar to what we just talked about a lot of these automated content analysis tools to understand why things catch on. We're beginning to look at how things combine, right? So obviously it's not just the words that someone uses. It's the way they use those words and in combination with the audio features
特征以及我们说话的速度，或者，你知道，我们是否在话语之间停顿，或者视觉特征，对吧？诸如我们移动双手的方式、面部表情或肢体语言之类的事情，所有这些事情确实可以帮助我们更有效地理解如何沟通，以及为什么产品、服务和想法能够流行起来。总而言之，你现在在做什么？你仍在试图回答的重大问题是什么？你知道，我认为类似于我们刚才讨论的很多这些自动化内容分析工具，来理解为什么事情会流行。我们开始研究事物是如何结合的，对吧？所以很明显，这不仅仅是某人使用的词汇。这是他们使用这些词汇的方式，并结合了音频特征
they utter and the visual features if they're there. You know, if you look at live stream, influencers live streams, for example, where they sell products. You know, it's about how they combine all these different modalities together. We have a project, for example, looking at how influencers convey empathy, both using their language, but also their body language and also their audio. The way they utter those words combines to think about impact. And so doing a lot of work on multimodal communication. Also thinking a lot about a very fundamental marketing question, but one I find very interesting, which is what are we selling? And how do you? And how do you? How is whether we're communicators, individuals, companies, organizations, we more effectively
他们发出的声音，如果有的话，还有视觉特征。你知道，如果你看看直播，例如网红的直播，他们卖产品。你知道，这是关于他们如何将所有这些不同的模态组合在一起。例如，我们有一个项目，研究网红如何传达同理心，既使用他们的语言，也使用他们的肢体语言和音频。他们说这些词的方式结合起来考虑影响力。因此，我们在多模态沟通方面做了很多工作。同时也在深入思考一个非常基础的营销问题，但我觉得非常有趣，那就是我们在卖什么？你怎么做？你怎么做？无论是传播者、个人、公司还是机构，我们如何通过了解我们的受众，真正思考我们卖的是什么以及我们如何为他们增加价值，来更有效地
get our messages and ideas out there by understanding our audience and really thinking about what is that thing that we're selling and how do we add value for them? You know, I think I use the phrase before good stuff isn't enough, but I find that very challenging. I, you know, consult with lots of companies and organizations. And often, whether it's an entrepreneur or a social cause. Often there are really good products, services, and ideas that don't take off. And so I think a lot about how to help both individuals and organizations make that good stuff spread more effectively. Well, Dr. Berger, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. I think it explains a lot for our audience. Thanks so much for having me.
把我们的信息和想法传达出去？你知道，我想我之前用过“好东西是不够的”这句话，但我发现这非常具有挑战性。我，你知道，为很多公司和机构提供咨询。通常情况下，无论是企业家还是社会事业。通常有很多真正好的产品、服务和想法并没有起飞。所以我经常思考如何帮助个人和机构让这些好东西更有效地传播。好的，伯杰博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。这真的非常有趣。我认为这为我们的观众解释了很多。非常感谢邀请我。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle.
您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学聊天》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学聊天》由李·温erman制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。在拉尔夫超市享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道都有的低价。
And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你下载拉尔夫应用时，你每周可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取燃料积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫超市，每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，凭借优惠和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 已有 150 多年的历史。省钱金额可能因州而异。燃料限制适用。详情请参见网站。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。